[Music]
the Carters relationship the good and
bad play out in their show they descend
hand-in-hand on an elevator platform no
doubt a reference to the TMZ posted 2014
Met Gala fight involving these sisters
the launch a source exclusively tells et
Beyonce and jay-z want to let fans into
their lives on their own terms they
start the show as a united front
symbolic of the couple working through
their previous issues closing out the
show this intimate moment projected on
to a screen it appears to show Beyonce
and jay-z renewing their vows all in
white surrounded by daughter Blue Ivy
and the twins homey in a flower crown
and her brother sir this ceremony may
have coincided with their 10th wedding
anniversary on April 4th
we're told both want this tour to be a
family affair and the three kids will be
traveling with mom and dad when they
came Beyonce's bringing a bunch of
bootylicious fashion on the road - how
about the three L's latex LeMay and
leopards all custom and some from the
house of Siobhan Sheen reckless when our
she wash the dress and get this the
designer behind this show ending black
bodysuit with detachable lace and hand
embroidered crystal skirt is the same
one who designed Meghan Markel's wedding
dress and loves making personal
consultation the special kind of
connection really helps them making
something absolutely perfect more deets
by the numbers forty seven shows run
through October featuring one ginormous
floating platform and two catwalks that
jet into the audience there are 17
dancers and a 26 person Orchestra
arranged vertically on stage
[Music]
[Applause]